we have a pressure to do it as observers
not participants right and because of
that you're always treading that line
between
giving everybody there a warm and
gracious show and welcome and make them
feel good and [__] on them
Oscars no I'll tell you I've hosted
three times I said I'll host under this
condition one if I'm the first thing out
there right because those moments are so
valuable that's when the audience is hot
and ripe and comedy is right you don't
want to follow a big dance number and go
out and win and all that you want to go
out and do your monologue yeah that's
what I wanted right and I said and no
interviews because I did I didn't want
the kids ask me what are you going to do
what are you going to think and I didn't
want to think about it just want to
concentrate on what I was going to do so
the first time I was in a state of cold
fear really yes and uh and then the
curtain goes up and you're fine because
you've done it a million times what is
the fear that you're going to flop and
it's not that it's just it's saying it's
uh what do you call it it's excitement
there's nerves it's nerves because
there's millions of people watching that
thing yeah yeah but you don't think
about that you really I always work to
the crowd in that room which I I I love
the crowd do you don't you think that
I'm very ripe for comedy but it's a
crowd that wants to be rewarded and
praise they are actors are overstating
it everybody's a person in there they're
you know of course they're nervous but
they're watching you know comedian do
comedy and they're fine I like the
audience and then you walked out and you
felt in command yes yeah but then the
second time I I thought okay and by the
way it was it was the night the Iraq
invasion oh started yeah and were you
thinking how can I make jokes if we've
just invaded Iraq but I had some
experience I was working at The Birdcage
theater yeah 1963 and Kennedy was shot
and so I'm going to work and think well
they can't possibly be doing a show
and uh we got then said the show's gonna
go on I thought this is going to be
awful and we went out and it was the
audience was really hot for some reason
and I thought it must be true about some
kind of Escape so I had this
understanding from you know 20 years ago
30 years ago
that of an audience's reaction in times
of stress and so I decided to
acknowledge uh what was going on and
then just go ahead and and it was
successful so you're seeing right at the
top you said look I'm aware that there's
you know
I said there was all this thing about
they were going to cut cut down on the
glitz and so that was my opening line
because looking around you know what it
looks like you know you really respected
that yeah well we really cut down on the
glitz and then just went on
is life unbelievable for you now I mean
unbelievable it's unbelievable right
better than you ever could have expected
I tell you man I walked on as host of
the Oscars and I was like I have no idea
how this happened but I'm going to enjoy
it I have no idea and you'll get nervous
before the Oscars I got yeah six weeks
before is when I got most nervous it
doesn't seem like you're real nervous up
there no when I went out on stage I was
like
I ever got was about eight years ago 10
years ago when I had to sing the
national anthem in front of a hundred
thousand people and I I was not a singer
right I lucked into a job in a musical
and I was freaking out I actually had a
panic attack the night before wow that's
the only time and I was like I don't
know why I'm doing this people have been
booed off doing that particular gig
right and when I got through that I was
sort of like everything else from that
moment's been okay I would think when
you go out there in front of the Academy
Awards and all that and it's all the
people you act with and all the people
all the directors producers everything I
would [__] my pants if it's no it's the
opposite you're out there and you're
looking first of all they know the
cameras are on them
they're not even looking at you no and
the other thing is there's an element
because I'm not a comedian and they're
looking at me like oh man they're a bit
for the grace of God go live what if I
was up there and they're like you can
see that good luck man we want it to go
well you poor bastard goodbye
you've said after the last Oscars you
are never hosting the Oscars again I
wouldn't say that I wouldn't host it
again I was incredibly honored to have
been asked to host it and I knew going
into it that it was going to be super
difficult in almost every way right but
I would never then say that I wouldn't
be honored to host it again but it's a
weird thing to say because if you say
that it sounds like you're trying to get
to host the Oscars again but it's not
like I'm out I'm done it was horrible
there were a lot of parts of it that
were really horrible but I think the
nature of that show is that there's so
much expectation to just simply watch it
and I think most people and why would
they have no appreciation of of just how
much goes into every single thing
somebody could ask me a singular thing
about any part of that four-hour
telecast and I could tell you a
20-minute story about what it what what
the joke was why it wasn't that what our
choices were why did this person fell
out and so we had to quickly get someone
to go into it and this you know I think
it's it's crazy it's a thankless job for
the host because I've said this before
you've got to do the balancing act where
you're sort of being nice to everyone
but yet you got to be edgy enough for
the audience and then if you try
anything out of the ordinary you can get
slammed for it when you came out in your
tidy whities you did the Birdman thing
yeah everyone said oh uh the critics
he's trying to show off his muscular
body or yeah did you take that as like
[__] you I mean do you get No I gave a I
didn't I'm not a [__] you kind of person
oh I read everything you read everything
pretty much everything and you don't get
affected by it no not really certain
sometimes people will say individual
things that seem like weird low blows uh
but no how do you not get affected by
that [__] you know why because I don't
believe you I seriously I would I'm more
I would be more paranoid if I didn't
read this stuff and I would be more
paranoid that they were saying worse
things about me as long as I'm process
processing the information then the onus
is on me to figure out how to deal with
it the fascinating thing too I always
want to talk to you about you've hosted
the Oscars you've hosted the Emmys and
you've hosted the Grammys like the grand
slam of all time is that fun for you you
would you would you continue to do like
if they said to you host the Oscars
would you do that no it's not fun right
it's thankless they asked me to do it
again this last year and I was like uh
no way why because it takes up a lot of
time or it does take especially doing
the show at the same time because I have
to start writing you know early on I
have to be ready for that and then you
don't know which movies are going to be
nominated so you don't know how strong
the jokes are going to be because it
depends on the movies that are nominated
and then the pressure again people
evaluate you based on the ratings
performance but but also it's the
ratings and the ratings sometimes are
determined by which movies come out
because people have to be interested in
the actors right and you get pinned if
the thing is not you get pinned with a
failure it's too much to risk but I did
have fun the last time I hosted I I had
a lot of fun you broke the internet in a
sense you you took us you decided to
take a selfie right and and were you
shocked by that response people went on
to see the selfie and it actually
crashed the uh in the web yeah so to
speak I hoped that it would do that I I
actually thought that might happen
um but the joke was going to be I said
Meryl you've broken the record for the
amount of oscars that you've won let's
try to break the record for the Tweet of
selfies and so it was going to be I said
so Meryl was in it and then I was going
to call as many people that would come
in and the whole joke for me was plan I
was planning on asking Merrill to get
out to take it so that she wasn't even
in the picture and I kept if you watch
the the tape is I kept saying Meryl can
you I can't reach Meryl and and Bradley
Cooper kept saying I'll take it I'll
take it and I was like no no and I I was
trying to get Merrell out of the seat
the whole joke was that she wouldn't
even be in the the retweet break Bradley
took the the picture and it became what
it was isn't that a crazy amount of
pressure too because you're on live
television probably the biggest audience
you know it's it's like the Super Bowl
you know it's huge right and now you've
kind of visualized in your head this
great bit I'm gonna do a selfie I'm
gonna go over to Meryl Streep I'm gonna
ask her blah blah blah blah blah and the
thing can tank horribly right I mean it
could seem like the longest two minutes
ever I don't know I never think that way
I I just thought this is going to be fun
and I knew fun people were near there so
I thought some people would I didn't
think
um Brad Pitt and Angie would jump in
right I thought maybe Brad would but
Angie's really shy and thought it would
be fun and I thought the pizza thing
could tank I was worried about the pizza
thing right the guy delivering people
everybody loved that and then this
amazing pizza guy that we found this
amazing story of like the American dream
right now he has his own pizza parlor
because of this whole thing I mean it's
maybe that's why you would never host
the Oscars again because you can't top
that and essentially go wait I did it
yeah you had this tremendous success
yeah maybe you say that's it you throw
down your bat and you get out of the
game okay do you agree with that I do
you do right yeah I do and I did so that
kind of thing goes through your mind
yeah yeah and listen the reason I did it
this last time is because as you know
when you do something that is natural to
you it doesn't it's not a challenge
anymore it's still fun and there's highs
and lows every single day they're better
days than others and
um I just I wanted to challenge myself
in between uh Ted and A Million Ways to
Die in the West you hosted the Oscars
now I thought you did a really good job
I mean you told a lot of funny jokes
some of them were edgy but the rule is
you can't make fun
of those people on their big night and
you did so was it a mistake in the end
to host the Oscars or would you do it
again if they asked no no I yeah I
suppose I would do it again no I don't
think it was a mistake at all I I had a
great time the room was fantastic yeah I
used to do stand up I've never felt so
much love for an audience as I did well
into the second hour of that because I
felt like they were still with me right
they were great afterwards
um were you nervous
no I I I I had a few drinks before I
went out there so I was fine don't you
think like for a guy who who you know
I'm not going to say hi but
psychologically you're hidden when you
do a cartoon and you're doing the voices
when you do Ted you're the hidden guy uh
for you to go out in front of millions
of people on Hollywood's biggest night I
would think you would [__] your pants
because you're not used to being the guy
in front of the camera the movie was
scarier the Oscars was you know you're
going out and you know you're reading
jokes off a prompter basically yeah and
and that doesn't uh nerve you and you
know if something happens you yes you'd
have to be on your toes a little bit if
something goes Haywire but do you have a
group of writers who stand backstage
because that's what I heard like Billy
Crystal would do you have a group of
riders in the commercials you discuss
what just happened and then they'll just
give you a couple of suggestions yeah
yeah we do that too yeah so it was fun
yeah it was a it was a blast I mean you
didn't mind the backlash afterwards win
no because because I don't think that it
comes from anywhere but the Press I I
think you know my interactions with with
you know people like Affleck and and
Clooney and Charlize after the fact you
know it's it's they were great I mean
they had a great time and and uh you
know the reaction from the public was
was very gratifying I think the the
Press loves to make you think that
there's outrage where there is none
it's the Oscars uh when you did it it
was easy dissociated did you pinch
yourself I think that's rarified air you
know rarified air and for a comic that's
like a big deal no question would you do
it again I would probably do it again
not sure if they would I think that
what's needed there is a slightly
different animal the problem with having
me do it
and it's a problem with maybe having
Dave do it and rock do it is we have a
pressure to do it as observers not
participants right and because of that
you're always treading that line between
giving everybody there a warm and
gracious show and welcome and make them
feel good and [__] on them
and it's and then for the host though
you feel that pressure because you're
there you're not a dick no but you don't
want to do this but you don't want to
disappoint your fans right but you don't
want to disappoint them either so now
you're playing both rooms right and
playing both rooms I can remember when I
did it the first time because the first
time I did it I thought I had it and in
the even in the room I thought it had it
nailed like that was one of those nights
where right after it was over we were
like high-fiving until the next day
we're like Stuart sucks you do it never
show your face again right you know it
was one of those things so when you get
a negative review for the uh Oscars did
it throw you did it was like oh [__] I
shouldn't have done it yeah it throws
you but not you know not for that long
you know because it is it's it's not one
of the things about the Oscars is you
know if my career was only hosting award
shows then I'd be like oh my God then
you're [__] what am I going to do now
the whole slap thing do you play it over
in your head like the subroter film and
go I if I had it to do over again I
would have marched out and thrown Will
Smith right the [__] out of that
building I mean
I don't know what I would have done if
the power were in my hands I
it was so it was so upsetting like and
people made fun of me for saying that it
was traumatizing but I don't think it
was traumatizing for me I think it was
traumatizing for all of us like it was
it was like it just was like Chris
Rock's my good friend like one of my
best friends and Questlove is also one
of my best friends like you know it's
this is a small town and the people who
live in New York could stay in New York
like we're close and so to see that
happen
to see your friend get hit and then uh
and also Will Smith who I've loved and
we've all loved forever like I've I
don't remember a time I didn't think I
love that guy and you know and I haven't
been around much violence
um right you know I didn't grow up
within the home or anything so
it was upsetting for so many reasons and
it was of saying to everyone everyone at
home who didn't even see what I saw it
was shocking and um it was a bummer but
you know for me I never I had no
I had no thoughts of like how it
affected me or my performance or
anything it was just upsetting as a
person
when you saw the Will Smith slap and all
that crap do you say to yourself thank
God
I don't host the Oscars because to me I
even found myself sitting there going
why isn't anyone coming out and helping
out Chris Rock the guy just got
assaulted on stage and you kind of want
to blame the host and say where are you
and you know if you had been the host
Jimmy they would have said that [__]
Jimmy Kimmel he's a coward he didn't
come out he didn't wrestle oh I would
have went right out there there would
have been no I wouldn't even have waited
for somebody to say something do you
think do you think absolutely absolutely
I would have went right out on on stage
because somebody needed to go out there
at that time and I think that was one of
the the the the drawbacks to having
three hosts is it wasn't clear who
should go out there and whose channel
right but when they mixed up the
envelopes and it nobody knew what was
supposed to happen I just no one told me
to go out on stage I said I guess I
better go up because I'm the only one
with a mic on you want to know something
I am now so [__] disappointed that
you didn't host the Oscars because what
a great moment if you would have been
clear-headed enough
you would have had the presence to say
[__] this and walked out and confronted
Will Smith in your mind how would you
have handled the dog what would you say
Hey will get in your [__] seat and
get or get out of the what would you
have done you think I think I probably
would have started talking to Will Smith
I think that would you know who was
sitting there I think I would have
opened like what are you what are you
doing like what why what you you know
and I think that that would have been my
first step did you call Chris Rock at
all or speak to him uh after that
incident I spoke to him for about 90
minutes probably six or seven days after
it it happened you called him at home
and said hey no no I in person um I I
saw him in person after Saturday Night
Live I was in New York and I talked to
him at length about it and I really
don't I don't want to share what he told
me because I don't think it's my story
to to share and I think that he's gonna
but um he was surprised by it
yeah
foreign